we begin again with breaking news help
may soon be on the way for an American
economy sent reeling by the corona virus
the White House and the Senate have
agreed to a roughly two trillion dollar
rescue package that's 12 zeroes for
those of you who are accounting that's
the largest in American history this
comes as a number of coronavirus cases
reported in the u.s. tops fifty five
thousand more than 800 people have died
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill for us
where stimulus negotiations went past
midnight but there was a breakthrough
Nancy good morning so what's next and
when will this financial help reach
actual everyday Americans well as
quickly Toni as the government can get
all this money out the door the Treasury
Secretary says that some of these cash
payments twelve out to $100 rather for
individuals $3,000 for many families can
be direct deposited but first Congress
has to vote the Senate plans to do that
later today and it's expected to pass
overwhelmingly the Senate has reached a
bipartisan agreement on a historic
relief package for this pandemic it was
the early morning announcement the
entire economy had been waiting for to
all Americans I say help is on the way
big help and quick help the massive bill
is designed to bring relief to workers
and businesses hospitals and state
governments and those who have already
lost their jobs boosting unemployment
insurance by $600 a week through July
it's crazy but we'll be fine
that money will help the forty
restaurant workers that Lisa Spooner and
Kevin Clarke restaurant tours in Atlanta
were forced to lay off last week we're
in a great country there's money we'll
just go further in debt I mean people
need help and money is the answer to
help other small businesses keep their
workers on the bill contains nearly 400
billion in grants plus another 500
billion in loans for major industries
like the Airlines there's also more than
130 billion dollars for the nation's
health care providers there is much more
money for our hospitals
for our nurses and physicians for our
nursing homes for our Community Health
Center's to do the job they need to do
and $1,200 for most individuals we're
gonna pass this legislation later today
things have been moving so quickly that
many senators will not have a chance to
read the entire bill before they vote on
it they're just going to have to trust
the negotiators and then once it passes
in the Senate has to go to the house
where they're hoping to pass it by
something called unanimous consent which
would enable them to do it without
bringing all the House members back to
Washington DC but Tony it would require
every House member to agree to that
let's hope they can find some agreement
every second counts in this Nancy thank
you very much